is there advice you can give to
young people today high schoolers
college students
taking on trying to figure out their
career trying to figure out their life
advice on how to succeed in either yeah
i think uh you know one thing i
was always interested when i was
teaching was like you'd have these you'd
have students
who had like interests they had what
they were good at and sometimes those
ran in in unison with one another other
times they didn't
and it was always interesting to me when
you'd have a student who's like i'm
really into
like you know guitar or i'm really into
skateboarding or something like that
where it's like
pretty small like success rate on that
avenue versus what you can maybe
accomplish by focusing on just something
like a little more standard and
i think like really like besides
the likelihood of it becoming something
you can turn into a profession or not
you should just ask yourself like is
this something that i want to spend
my free time doing uh and because if it
is
then you want to keep that in your life
because that's something that's
rewarding motivating it might be the
catalyst that gets you out of bed in the
morning and you know go to another job
in order to go do that thing afterwards
i think nowadays we're getting to a
point where like
the your reachability from even a really
small
like unmonetized thing previously
is now an option where if like you live
in a city where there's only two other
people interested in your topic of area
so you're not gonna turn into a job now
with the internet you have the world at
your disposal so
that two to three people in every town
can turn into thousands tens of
thousands hundreds and millions of
people and if you
really focus your time and energy into
that thing then you know who knows where
you can go and how much more enjoyable
your life can be if you're able to turn
your career into a passion of yours so
i think like that is something i would
tell
tell people um folks on that see the
thing you're
good at and it kind of sparks that flame
and uh go with that even if society
doesn't really want you to
uh like it's non-traditional
and the odds are low of like
traditionally defined success
just do that thing i've struggled with
that it's like it was always clear
especially like in school there's stuff
i'm actually good at
and stuff that the world wants me to do
right yeah and i kept the world wanted
me to be a plumber when i took that test
my sophomore year
but even like like academically just
going to university and
uh academia there are certain ways even
in
i would say even in the thing you want
to do
the way you do that thing the world will
want you to do it a certain way
and even just like finding your way of
doing that thing
is really powerful like for me the way i
do research
the way i learn is is different than
colleagues of mine and i've realized
that
that i really like to follow things i'm
passionate about versus sort of the
rigor of studying ever
like the fundamentals all across the
board and building up and castle
um on the fundamentals like layer upon
layer just there's a bunch of details in
the way i
pursue the very thing that i currently
do that's different than others
and it took me quite a long time to
accept like you don't need to do it the
way
everyone else is doing it doesn't not
everyone else but majority people are
telling you to do it
because one it's beneficial to do it
different because then you'll
more likely stand out and two like why
the hell are you doing it the way it's
not working for you
yeah you know i saw that all the time
when i was teaching i was
dual certified i was my my
certifications were in
history and broadfield social studies so
like econ
psychology history all that stuff
and then i also had a certification of
special education which was
you know people think of special
education a lot of times as like oh it's
the
you know the kid who is not smart enough
to do the regular thing when reality
it's like
i mean there is some you know there's
obviously like you know like
certain things like down syndrome and
stuff like that but like there's also
like a huge population of groups of
both like gifted and talented on one end
of the spectrum where
they're incredibly smart and they're
like the geniuses
but for whatever reason the standard
method of learning does not click with
them does not work with them and then
they just need a slightly different path
or maybe a drastically different path
and they're gonna just flourish
and you have kids that end up falling on
the other end where you know
maybe it's really difficult for them to
be able to read at the speed
of other students but if you give them
this specific
direction they can just thrive in a
certain area and just
seeing that like the you know like that
there's
multiple ways to do stuff and there's
not necessarily one path to the end
is i think such an eye-opening thing to
learn especially if you learn maybe
that's what i should answer the question
that you asked me with is you know keep
an open mind as to what paths there are
forward and
know that you know maybe just because
even even if
you look to your left knee to the right
and all your classmates are successful
doing it one way it doesn't necessarily
mean that's going to be the way for you
you